-Thank you so much
for being here, bud.
It's always good to talk to you.
I wanted to say,
before we even
get into the interview,
how great you were on --
I watched the Mike Tyson Triller
boxing --
the match where you were there.
You were a commentator,
but you also performed.
And you stole the show
for me, dude.
You were unbelievable.
Everything top-notch.
-We had a great time too, Jimmy.
It was a great night.
It was a coming-out night
for me, basically.
A lot of people knew
that I was doing that.
But to be on that stage,
and to be able
to pull it off
in front of the whole world.
Now we're doing one
on April 17th,
which is a follow-Up fight,
and it's very well produced.
We got a lot of great acts
performing.
Big fights that night.
April 17th, we doing it again.
-Yeah, I want to talk to you
about that.
First, also, I want to give you
props on your jacket.
That's your --
That's "Doggystyle."
That's your first --
That's your first record.
-Yeah, that's the jacket that's
on The Snoopermarket right now.
If y'all want to go to
snoopermarket.com,
y'all can pick up one.
You understand me?
-That's my home page.
-Yeah, Snoopermarket, baby.
Come get you some.
-Yeah, Snoopermarket.
That's my -- I use that
more than Google, man.
[ Laughter ]
You've worked with so many great
artists throughout your career.
Obviously, the great DMX, sadly,
passed away on Friday.
I know you worked with him.
The last thing I saw,
you guys were doing
the Verzuz Battle.
What did it mean for to you
to share the stage with him?
-It meant the world because
it gave the world a chance
to see two dogs
that naturally love each other
celebrate each other
in the name of hip-hop.
You're seeing a lot of,
interaction between me and him,
engaging in our songs.
You're seeing a lot of
conversations and a lot of love.
And we had God in the building
with us that night.
And that makes me feel good
about DMX's transition
to know that he's
off to a better place
and he's finally got
his angel wings.
-Yeah.
When did you first meet him?
Do you remember?
-At a concert
at Trafalgar Square.
19 -- I think it was like, '94.
And then we went back
to the studio after that.
That was the first time
I actually met DMX.
-What comes to mind when you
think about that -- that night?
-He brought up a story
that was so -- so -- so deep
and instrumental
to our relationship.
He was like, "When you first met
me, I was, like, away from Him.
And He was saying,
'What's happening? What's up?'
And I was like,
'Get at me, dog.'"
He was like, "I took that and
I made that into my song,
'Get At Me Dog.'
'cause the way you got at me
and said that,
I was like, 'That's slick.'"
So, that night inspired him
to create that song
"Get At Me Dog,"
which was one of his biggest
hood records that he put out.
-Oh, my gosh.
I appreciate you talking to us
about this.
I know it just happened.
So thank you very much
for doing that.
And we're gonna miss him.
-Jimmy, it's what we do.
We keep hip-hop alive,
and legends never die.
Their soul will continue
to, you know, bless the world.
And he was a great,
you know, spirit.
He always
looked out for everybody.
He always prayed for everybody,
So now we can finally say
he got his angel wings and
he's off to a better place.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Thanks, man.
[ Applause ]
Something that I've always
loved about you is
not only your work
as a great hip-hop legend,
but you're also --
as a businessman.
You're always working on
something brand-new.
I want to say,
probably twice a year,
I get a nice gift from you,
and I appreciate it.
I get -- I think the last thing
I received was a gin --
a juice-flavored gin --
with beautiful cups.
Of course, gin and juice --
you got to do that.
-Yeah, that's my company.
INDOGGO Gin.
-You've now started
a boxing league with Triller,
called Fight Club.
And this Saturday, big fight.
What is the fight
happening on Saturday?
-Jake Paul versus Ben Askren.
This is gonna be a great fight
because there's been
a lot of conversation
between the two.
Jake is a YouTube star,
but he's a great fighter,
and Ben is a former UFC champ.
So it's a lot of, you know,
bad blood between these two.
And they're gonna
get in the ring and get it on.
And this Fight Club
is about that.
It's about people
who really want to get down
and, you know,
have a great fight
and not have to wait for
certain rules and regulations.
But just to get in where
they fit in and fight it out.
So we put that together
because we felt like
the world needed that.
We also got another fight
on there that's called
"Gloves Up Guns Down."
And it's two fighters
that are from the neighborhood.
Two different neighborhoods,
and they finally
came to an agreement
to have a fight
instead of shooting each other,
so we putting that on the plate,
too, as far as
giving opportunities
to those who want to settle
their differences
other than a violent way,
but a legal fighting way.
-I love that.
I think that's great.
[ Applause ]
It's not just boxing,
because it's like an event,
because there's great music.
You got Justin Bieber,
you got Doja Cat, you got Diplo.
-Black Keys.
Then you got Mt. Westmore,
my group,
which is me, Ice Cube, Too
$hort, and E-40.
We debuting, you know,
one of our songs that night.
And we performing that night,
as well.
-Mt. Westmore! I love this!
Too $hort, E-40 --
-And Ice Cube.
-And ice Cube. Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I should tell for everyone,
to get more information
on upcoming fights,
go trillerfightclub.com.
Next week,
we get more Snoop Dogg,
because you're this season's
mega mentor on "The Voice."
Now, this is fun.
-They let me on "The Voice."
Hey, Jimmy,
they let me on "The Voice."
Can you believe it?
-I can't. I can't.
I won't believe it
till I see it.
-Man, I had a good time, too.
I had a great time
with the artists,
with the coaches.
It was a great experience.
It was really motivating
for them and me, as well,
'cause I learned a little bit,
and I'm pretty sure
they learned a little bit
from me.
It was a great scenario,
a great situation,
'cause I was able to tap into
certain genres of music
that I actually really love
and know about
and, you know,
give some critiquing.
-Yeah, I like
that Blake Shelton,
in the clip I saw,
he didn't know
that you knew that much
about country music,
and you were like,
"Oh, no, no, no. I know."
-Man, I'm dipped and whipped
in their country songs.
You understand me?
From Johnny Cash on down.
you know what I mean?
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Yeah, I'm sure you and Willie
have had some nights that...
-Oh boy. That's my guy.
That's the only one.
He's the only one to ever
make me push "pause"
in a smoke session.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Wow!
Well, I want to show a clip.
Here's Snoop Dogg
on "The Voice."
Take a look at this, everybody.
-When I looked at you,
I did not know
that you could project
all of that.
-Out of that little bitty thing?
-You come up here all like...
And then, when the mic is on,
you were, like, gigantic.
-Thank you.
-And you know
how to held them notes, too,
girl.
-[ Chuckling ] Thank you.
-I love it.
The only thing I am missing is
those little intimate
little things that you do,
like moody vibes,
and then move into
that kind of big place.
The complete juxtaposition
of what the end of the song
is gonna be.
-Yeah.
-More of that, like...
♪ I've been roamin' around ♪
♪ Always looking down
at all I see ♪
-Yeah.
-Yeah, let the music find you.
-Okay.
-Yes.
-You got to look at yourself
as one of those instruments
being played.
Don't try to catch the beat.
They'll catch you.
You just find your groove
and make it smooth.
Converse with us.
Make us feel what you sing.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Snoop Dogg, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I miss you, man.
Always good to see you.
I miss you.
Come back soon, alright?
You can see him on "The Voice,"
which airs Mondays at 8:00 p.m.
on NBC.